So I thought this month we'd have a look at this fear and anxiety since there's so much of it.
No need to mention names, what's causing all the problems.
in terms i mean there are words in pali which separate fear and anxiety but for our purposes we can put them all into one just this word fear um the way we act the way we experience fear is is a sudden jolt of a bad energy in the body and it tends to go away so if you step out on the road and a car just misses you you get that fright whereas
and it tends to be it tends to be paralyzing and cold i think whereas anxiety is something long-term it's always about the future it's always what's going to happen next and uh we tend to feel that as an agitation and and it warms us up it heats us up so there's quite a sort of a difference between them but for our purposes as i say uh you know fear will do
so uh whenever we talk about things like this always go back to the root problem and there of course we find the dear old self so this is the delusion of some body some person which has a reality to it so remember that uh even the buddha has a personality it's not though you it's not as though you lose your personality when you become liberated
uh but you lose that sort of uh sense of self being isolated from uh a sense of disconnect and this manifests of course mainly uh when we come across death so that's our old our old friend death and um anything that anything that suggests
endings always reminds us of that ultimate state, which, you know, brings fear.
It's the unknowability when it'll happen.
We don't know what will happen after death.
We might have a certain faith, a certain belief that we carry on.
On the other hand, we might think we just disappear.
But whatever it is, nobody actually wants to die.
now from that sense of self of course we try to buffer ourselves against the world uh to protect ourselves from the world and and from from that fear of losing so we we attach to things you know we gather wealth friends power uh we like to absorb into sensual pleasures and become attached to that sort of thing going on holidays sex drugs rock and roll
and and of course the more things we have the more people are friends and etc etc the more we can lose and therefore with that attachment there also comes fear so the buddha in the dharma part of states it quite clearly from attachment comes grief from attachment comes fear one who is free from attachment has no grief so how can there be fear
So how do we overcome it?
Well, first of all, there's just the reflection.
So we've done, you know, a past moon celebration.
We wandered into the idea of death, sickness, aging and all that.
And it's sort of bringing that up as often as we want just to get accustomed to the idea of sickness, aging and death.
um and it's through it's through that sort of uh a cusp that that sense of being okay with the feelings that come up with that that is part of purifying the heart of its fear of it yeah so one who is wise and full of insight does not tremble in the face of death
and then there's meta now you have to be careful meta isn't there to sort of bury it to push it away to sort of suppress it method is there as a way of approaching it yeah i'm sure you've heard me speak about um holding things with that sense of care so if
we find ourselves being anxious being afraid of things you know especially you know with the news and all that and it can bring up a certain sense of fear and anxiety about what's happening in the world just to stay with the feeling and to embrace it with a sense of care and remember you can always talk to the heart you know dear heart i can feel you i know you're in a dreadful state
but you know we'll just stay here for a little while and i'm sure that you'll release that energy see so by creating that sort of distance between what you're feeling and uh and and what is doing the feeling you're allowing that energy to dissipate so as a way of of coming to terms with fear and of allowing that that sensation to die away
so what we're heading for of course is fearlessness and part of the practice of vipassana is to do with that but remember you can do it at any time if there's the occasion if you're on your own for instance as you'll see from a reading that I'll be giving from the discourses
uh you can just sit with it for a while that's all and you just you know sometimes it can be quite quite heavy i mean even feelings of nausea so you just sit with it you see and that that lack of reaction because you know allows the heart to heal itself so remember every time we're reacting pushing it away the energy of pushing it away is actually becoming part of that of that fear
And if we allow the anxiety to run away with those thoughts, then it's going to grow.
So with those two ways of dealing with it, as soon as we realize we're doing that, stop and just open up to what the heart wants to say.
So, okay, so I've just chosen a passage really to show us how the Buddha himself dealt with it.
And it's much the same as we've been talking.
So it's nice to know that he went through the same problems.
So it's called the Discourse of Fear and Dread.
And a Brahmin, Janusoni, goes to see him and there's the usual exchange of greetings and little niceties.
And then he says to the Buddha, remote jungle thicket places in the forest are hard to endure.
Seclusion is hard to practice and it is hard to enjoy solitude.
One would think the jungles would rob a meditator of their minds if they have no concentration.
So the Buddha agrees with that and then he lists a whole load of things that if we suffer from these things it's going to be hard to sit in solitude.
So it's unpurified of bodily conduct, verbal conduct, covetousness and full of lust, ill will and intentions of hate, sloth and torpor, restlessness and unpeacefulness in mind, uncertain and doubtful,
given to self-praise and disparaging others, subject to alarm and terror , desirous of gain, honour and renown, lazy and wanting in energy, unmindful and not fully aware, unconcentrated, with straying minds, devoid of wisdom, idiots.
Such people will find it very difficult
to find solitude in the forests in the jungle thicket resting places so now he says of himself that he felt that he wasn't suffering from all that very much and so he decides there are especially auspicious nights of the 14th 15th and the 8th of the fortnight so this is the moon calendar
now what if on such nights as these i i were to dwell in such awe-inspiring hair-raising abodes as orchard shrines woodland shrines and tree shrines so these shrines were where the gods were and some of them weren't particularly nice um interestingly enough he doesn't he doesn't hear suggests that he went to sit in the um the channel grounds uh
to overcome the fear of death here he is talking about these shrines and of course he's there during the night
I dwelt in such awe-inspiring, horrifying abodes as orchard shrines, woodland shrines and tree shrines.
And while I dwelt there, a wild animal would come up to me or a peacock would knock off a branch or a wind would rustle the leaves.
And I thought, what now if this is the fear and dread coming, right?
So he's gone to experience this fear and dread.
And then I thought, why do I always dwell expecting fear and dread?
what if i soothe that fear and dread while keeping the same posture that i'm in when it comes upon me so he stops expecting this fear and dread however it does come and he says while i walked the fear and dread came upon me i neither stood nor sat nor lay down till i had soothed that fear and dread
While I stood, the fear and dread came upon me.
I neither walked nor sat nor lay down till I had soothed the fear and dread.
And while I sat, the fear and dread came upon me.
I neither walked nor stood nor lay down till I had soothed the fear and dread.
And while I lay down, the fear and dread came upon me.
I neither walked nor stood nor sat down till I had soothed that fear of dread.
So there he is, you see, he went through the same sort of rubbish that we have to go through.
Now, so that's to do with, shall we say, fear as something unwholesome.
But interestingly enough, fear can be wholesome.
And one writer calls it the paradox of fear.
so take a very simple instance why don't we just step out on the road and cross to the other side right because you know within us there's a fear of being knocked over and it's it's reminding ourselves of that even if it's only in the background even if it's only to say subconscious we know that if we don't take care and we walk out into the road you know we may very well have a serious accident
so there are two qualities that he points to which are uh should we say uh wholesome fear and that's the the dread of consequences and shame so he gives a whole list of things that we should be afraid of in terms of consequences some of them you know pretty straightforward things like misconduct of of body speech and mind
But he also talks about famine, catastrophes, schisms.
So these things are, should we say, being afraid, being afraid of famine and catastrophes and things like that.
We prepare for them, right?
So as you know, we've had floods in this country and we finally have done a little bit about them.
So knowing that there are going to be catastrophes, there are going to be famines, you build up a situations where you can undermine them.
so this fear of things going wrong and the fear of doing things which are unwholesome and will have consequences that sort of fear is a wholesome fear it stops us doing things or it makes us do things for our own personal benefit the other one is shame so shame is you know when we feel that we've lost
esteem in people's eyes if we do something that they see or hear and that of course is something that we don't like at all but it's also at times when we have thought something or we do something where nobody's around but we just feel that you know it's not something that I expect of myself
I had an old aunt who used to say, if I did that, it wouldn't be me.
So it's that sort of understanding about how we feel when we do something that humiliates us, that we feel that our worthiness in people's eyes and in our own eyes has been undermined.
So fear and dread of consequences
in the Buddha's understanding are actually our guardians they stop us doing unwholesome things and it's interesting that the academics who study this are sort of confounded by it like I mean to me it seems pretty straightforward you know so they one of them conjured up this phrase the paradox of fear okay so
there we have it you know in short um how you know the roots of fear and anxiety based on this self and attachment to things how we deal with it through loving kindness and insights vipassana and allowing that energy to dissipate and how uh some fears that we have and some uh loss of face of the fear of the loss of face um are actually our protectors yeah
Very good.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and that by your careful investigation of fear you will be liberated from all fear sooner rather than later.